un autre cercueil une autre victime de
la coved 19 elles sont des centaines
enterrés dans ce cimetière de jakarta en
indonésie des images dures qui témoigne
une fois de plus de l'ampleur de la
pandémie depuis neuf mois le coronavirus
a fait plus d'un million de morts dans
le monde
un cap symbolique des millions
d'infections dans des centaines de pays
et le nombre de nouveaux cas augmente
toujours rapidement particulièrement en
asie la pandémie dure depuis trop
longtemps dit cet homme
les gens ont besoin d'un rappel pour
redoubler d'efforts l'inde qui compte
certaines des villes les plus densément
peuplées du monde des nombreux près de
cent mille victimes de la coved 19
c'est l'un des pays où le virus a été le
plus meurtrier
après le brésil et les états unis tant
de vies touché par la pandémie
cette résidente de houston au texas
originaire du guatemala a perdu son
frère le mois dernier ça me fait de la
peine dit johanna ça me fait mal au
coeur de penser à lui
alfonso avait immigré avec elle aux
états unis il est l'un des 200 milles
américain emporté par la maladie
je n'ai plus envie de sortir
explique-t-elle plus envie de travailler
elle est une victime collatérale de la
pandémie
ceux qui sont restés derrière se sont
réunis à madrid justice pour les
victimes du coronavirus représenté par
ces milliers de petits drapeaux
l'espagne est le pays d'europe le plus
durement touchés alors qu'aura n'en chez
nous sont apparus les premiers cas de la
maladie en décembre dernier la vie
semble avoir repris son cours
cette résidente a l'impression que la
vie a retrouvé le goût d'avant tout le
monde amour en ce sens bien ajoutent
elles un contraste frappant avec le
silence des rues désertes ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada morrell